the u.s government has been auctioning
off bitcoin what yes the u.s government
has had a lot of bitcoin and they
continue to auction it off now what the
report is coming in is that the us
government has been seizing bitcoin in
various operations and alongside other
assets so this is not just the
government going in and seizing bitcoin
what happens is they go in and they
seize a person's assets usually during a
criminal uh investigation or something
like that and they happen to have some
bitcoin now the three main junctures in
the flow of crypto through the criminal
justice system is basically first phase
there is search and seizure the second
is that there's a liquidation of rated
crypto and the third is deployment of
the proceeds from those crypto sales so
that's kind of the three steps here of
what actually occurs we have a quote
from jared kuppman the director of cyber
crime unit at the irs he says it could
be 10 boats 12 cars and then one of the
lots is x number of bitcoin being
auctioned so basically what happens is
that through the government one of the
either law enforcement agencies the irs
et cetera there's some sort of seizure
of assets inside those assets ends up
being bitcoin and then ultimately what
they do is they turn around and they
auction them off so how much exactly has
actually been seized in the fiscal year
of 2019 they had about 700 000 worth of
crypto seizures in 2020 it was up to 137
million dollars they went from 700k to
137 million and so far in 2021 they're
at
1.2 billion dollars those are big boy
and big girl numbers 700k to 137 million
to 1.2 billion dollars absolutely going
parabolic
and not necessarily for a good reason
and so jared then goes on and says that
it's not about timing the market it's
actually the exact opposite you
basically get in line to auction it off
we don't ever want to flood the market
with a tremendous amount which then
could have an effect on the pricing
component so quite literally we have the
director of cyber crime at the irs
saying that they don't want to time the
market and they also don't want to sell
all the bitcoin in bulk that would crash
the price they're trying to be
thoughtful but this is pretty crazy that
they've got so much crypto that that has
been seized and in july the u.s marshals
service they hired anchorage digital as
their custodian to help custody the
cryptocurrency that was seized or
forfeited in various criminal cases
hardware wallets are also used to secure
the c's crypto and jared said we
maintain private keys only in
headquarters so that it can't be
tampered with it is pretty crazy to
think of the us government having
hardware wallets actually maintaining
private keys and then holding on to
bitcoin or other cryptocurrencies until
they go ahead and they actually auction
that stuff off and so ultimately the
crypto that's traced and seized accounts
for roughly 60 to 70 of the treasury
forfeiture fund making it the largest
individual contributor inside of the us
government are we surprised that they
are seizing so much of this and
auctioning it off or is this some you
know just like any other asset whether
it's cars houses or other types of
investment i think they're treating it
like any other asset i'm not surprised
that they have almost doubled tripled
like always increased year by year since
2018 of the amount that they've seized
because people just there's bad actors
in every single asset right there
there's bad actors that use cars they go
ahead and seize them and then they go
ahead and auction them off to the public
um but i think it is interesting that
they don't hold it um it kind of just
makes sense to hold it to be honest if
you look at the appreciation over the
last 12 years of bitcoin and then also i
read a quote um that they were talking
about how they don't try and time the
market but they don't dump all their
bitcoin at one time right or other
cryptocurrencies at one time because
they cannot it can affect the price
right i don't want my government trading
on uh certain assets like this but it's
not surprising that they do this at all
the auctions look tell me where to go
because i'm sure i'm sure you can get a
lot of bitcoin for for a good price one
of the pieces that uh is not surprising
is that they're forfeiting the assets
right so that is uh just like they
forfeit any other asset what i am
surprised by is the fact that they are
auctioning and auctioning it off and
they've been doing this for a long time
and they haven't chosen yet to hold the
assets uh on their balance sheet
there may be rules that preclude them
from doing that
but i think that's one piece the second
is that if they were able to hold it
that would have uh
pervase uh incentives right if all of a
sudden the government was incentivized
to seize people's assets and then hold
on to them i don't think we want to live
in that world so there's a
delicate balance between hindsight being
20 20 and it obviously uh the bitcoin
that they seized rather than having
auctioned it off to tim draper or
anybody else they should have held on to
it that's obvious but the opposite is
also true which is i don't think as
private citizens we want the government
law enforcement uh or other types of
regulatory bodies to actually have the
incentive to seize assets and hold them
for long periods of time right then all
of a sudden you get in this weird world
where it becomes a zero-sum game and so
uh really what i think is uh kind of the
most interesting piece of this is that
an asset that most people say like oh i
hold the private keys oh i have
sovereignty uh the government's able to
obviously seize my guess is that
majority if not all of those seizures
are coming because people are holding
the assets on
exchanges it's not because they have
their private keys and they show up
and get it instead what's happening is
it's on
kind of a regulated exchange the
exchange gets told hey there's some sort
of criminal investigation there's some
sort of enforcement action we want you
to go ahead freeze those assets give
them to us we're gonna seize them and
then we're gonna go ahead and we're
gonna auction it off so there's a lot of
complexity here but uh i'm just blown
away 700k to 137 millions and over a
billion dollars 700 k to over a billion
dollars in you know essentially two
years
that's big-time growth i'll be
interested to see when the u.s
government actually starts to earn yield
on the bitcoin that they're holding in
between the time that they seize it and
the time that they auction it off i
don't think they're gonna do that i
think they're gonna do that why would
they not do it because i don't i think
they take the position that they're not
in the investment game
yeah well they should be
20. 28 trillion dollars in debt they
should be in the investment game
i mean you're not wrong on that
you do you think that they could
bleeding money as a nation yeah well uh
we don't have money we're broke we're
printing it yeah we're well we just can
create money so we don't actually need
to make any revenue like why become an
investor when you could just print money
imag imagine how much investing you
would do if you could just go in your
bank account just edit the number in
there every day
it'd be pretty nice yeah well i just
would not invest
right right why do i need to be an
investor i could just edit the number
like i don't need to be an investor yeah
well we'll see what they do over time
they just did anchorage digital i think
it was that they're going to start
holding some of their bitcoin as well
and then they obviously they hold on a
hardware wall which is that's why yeah
that's why off chain can't move it
around as easily what do you auction off
a usb stick at all you're like all right
this one's got xml bitcoin that's
probably what they do unfortunately but
uh the government auctions are crazy to
begin with and to think that they're
auctioning off cryptocurrency assets i
mean what if they
are they seizing stocks and auctioning
those off as well
uh they probably are either liquidating
or auctioning yeah they probably
liquidate it though they probably i
would be surprised if they auction off
all the stocks i don't know what they do
with stocks that would be pretty crazy
if they were like yo hey come buy amazon
stock 90 cents on the dollar 90 cents on
the dollar going once going once going
at a discount as well yeah well or maybe
people will pay a premium
why would someone pay a price like let's
say that they they let's just say they
seized el chapo's amazon stock would you
pay a premium for to say i own amazon
stock but i don't just own any amazon
it's like i own el chapo's i would not
but i bet some people would somebody out
there would
like like you mean you get this like
weird world where like uh you can make
an argument yeah sure it should be
discounted right uh uh or at fair market
value but there are people out there who
depending on who it is would absolutely
pay more from